Just make sure on global climate that
we're talking about more than climate
and that you understand what climate
means.
There's a great argument that global
climate change,
which has become warmer,
has actually been a real positive.
We have less people freezing to death
even though we have some that are dying
and is that where the highest priority
for our resources is red or is it fight
email?
You mail nutrition,
malnutrition around the world.
Whereas if fighting malaria around the
world are HIV aids.
If you gave me $200,000,000,000 to go
spend over the next 10 years,
global climate will be the last place
I'd put that money.
It would be in the malnutrition.
It would be in a malaria,
it'd be an HIV aids.
That's what we need to decide as a
world.
It's sort of like giving a new heart to
a 90 year old.
Do you give that new heart to a 10 year
old or do you give it to 90 year old?
You've got to make choices because there
are limited resources at the end of the
day and if I'm going to end up being
taxed for $100,000,000,000 worth of cost
is a consuming nation of energy.
I want to make sure those taxes go to
the best places we can for the world's
wealth and health,
health and welfare,
and I vote for doing that on the side of
hunger and disease way before I try to
create,
try to fight the fiction that I think
has been hoisted on us about what CEO is
really doing and we have to absolutely
educate ourselves just as I'm doing
right now about what is really causing
the problem.
Is it actually he the warmth the globe
causing ceo to to rise or is it CO2
causing the the heat of the globe to go
up and importantly,
if it is going up because of manmade
emissions,
is it all bad or is it actually arguably
somewhat good?
Is the Arctic actually melting because
of the wind changes or because of co?
Two is the Antarctic actually losing
five percent of its ice in one part and
growing out of 95 percent more,
make sure we get all the points of the
story and that we don't have special
interest groups lobbying groups,
whether it's the oil industry,
whether it's the environmental movement
or whether it's politicians or other
ngos telling us how the world ought to
work.
Let's get educated all of us on her own
and get past the rhetoric and actually
make tough,
tough economic choices based on where
our hurt says the world ought to go.